Obama's life has never been easy his
home back in Syria was bombed and
destroyed by Syrian government forces in
2014.
left with no other option abrahamut
fella to turkey with his family
where he sells candy on the streets of
the southern city of gazante to provide
for his family
but now with the Turkish economy
faltering and inflation skyrocketing he
is struggling even more
poor people are dying slowly the prices
went from 30 to 300 percent nothing
Remains the Same only my work and income
remain the same my single room house
rent is 1200 Lira I need 40 Lira a day
just for the rent but I only make 30
Lira per day how am I going to pay we
hope that someone will help us
diabetes and needs treatment
but he has no public health coverage and
is unable to afford medicines given his
meager income
as a result his health is deteriorating
rapidly a decade ago War forced millions
of syrians to leave their homes to make
a new beginning in Turkey but with its
economy in crisis and inflation soaring
their lives here are becoming
increasingly difficult
most syrians know the hardship of Life
very well khalida Muhammad left his
country in 2018 when he felt his family
was in danger of being killed by the
Syrian government he was detained after
his first attempt to leave the Syrian
city of Dara and he spent more than a
year in prison however he succeeded in
coming to Turkey on his second attempt
Khalil used to be an I.T engineer in
Syria but now he is forced to work as a
construction worker in gaziantep where
his co-workers often joke about his
degree
my colleagues say if I'd worked as a
construction worker in Syria it would be
better for me instead of studying
engineering because here I can't make
use of it I'm trying to cut down on
expenses the high cost of living is
making it impossible to meet our basic
needs but at least my children are safe
here but given my low salary it's
difficult to build a future for them
war in their country Syrian refugees
were hoping for a better and safer life
in Turkey but many say they now plan to
seek Asylum somewhere else ideally in a
European country however with so many
financial and legal obstacles that dream
seems
far-fetchedu Sardar Al Jazeera gaziantep
turkey